[Music]
and can't touch this news submitted by
where's Ryan winky face
oh he's in this room no side buddy come
outside the barns a London school
principal has banned students from
playing in the snow okay what happens
long who's bitter cuz they don't want
them but get hurt that's got to be the
fun world though maybe they were they
were eating too much yellow snow
is it true that if you're cold and
you're stuck out there in the wilderness
and it's snowing and you should bury
yourself in the snow that keeps you
warmer I heard something like that like
you could like the igloo effect yeah but
I think I have to pack the snow and it
turns it like like that like styrofoam
like it's an insulator now so you can't
just be like soft snow I think you gotta
like dig a little hole you got high oh
yeah I remember we talked about on Jay
King these where people made their own
igloo in their backyard with snow and
then they had to take it down cuz then
they started renting it out on Airbnb
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right I
can't imagine somebody having to take
down an igloo like I feel like should
just go away until it is melted I know
this isn't that so what's up with mr.
Krampus over here huh yeah so this
headmaster he had master he appeared on
Good Morning good morning Britain
oh they got one of those out there huh
mm-hmm and so he's just explaining like
the reason why because other schools are
banning snowball fights that's like a
con leche it's crazy but this dude is
taking it one step further and banning
the kids from even touching the snow Wow
how can you I'm gonna play a clip of his
interview and good morning Britain
well you look evil as [ __ ] the rules are
don't touch the snow if you don't touch
this now you're not gonna throw it but
also there's the thing about being fit
for work you know that being ready for
school if you're soaking wet your hands
you're cold you you know you've been
involved in a fight you've had something
thrown it last thing you do before you
go into school into the classroom is
have a snowball in your face you're not
ready what kind of kids are you creating
Piers Morgan Dagenham right yeah
The Jerusalem Community College yeah do
you think there's a danger if you put it
in so much cotton wool no because I had
snowball fights
I got occasionally a bit wet went to
school in my wet clothes I didn't die
I'm fine but you didn't operate what you
didn't operate in is in a society where
by the first thing that happens a parent
is on the phone to that company to make
that claim and I'm responsible mm-hmm
who's covering his own ass so he doesn't
mind a kid do it after school yeah and
he's like talking about the lawsuits
these days the parents all that [ __ ]
that makes sense yeah cuz he said quote
the problem is it only takes one student
one piece of grit one stone in a
snowball in an eye with an injury and we
change our view yeah that's true
absolutely actually being smarter yeah
we live in a super hypersensitive world
because during Piers Morgan's age the
parents probably didn't give a damn yeah
or they wouldn't be coming up in likes
you could look up I think yet what kids
do yeah this old picture this like black
and white or sepia coloured photo of
like these Princeton students who had a
snowball fight before their class
picture the face is just like golf ball
lump right here is like from back in the
day I mean that's just how it was I
guess cool that's time kids can't be
kids anymore I know a lot of people are
saying like are you kidding me like
you're such a fun killer you can't even
touch this love what is not his fault
though cuz he doesn't want to get sued
he doesn't want to liability yeah like
that's it's the parents that are being a
little [ __ ] that report and come in and
be like well my student my kid got
[ __ ] up in your school so imma sue you
for five million dollars like we're the
supervisors down huh he says it's a duty
of care yeah plus a lot of it though is
the headline to because the headline
doesn't say it headmaster banned snow in
fear of lawsuits a [ __ ] has parents
yeah it says like headmaster forbids
kids from playing in snow so he just
looks like the [ __ ] yeah they make
him look bad just for that things are
pretty dumb though I'm my brother Aaron
I've just because we used to watch a lot
of like 80s Early 90s kung fu movies we
used to imitate
a lot so I remember one time on why this
popped in my head but we started
punching each other in the stomach just
to see just to see who could handle it
better and we would just start stalking
each other all the time Steve green
summarized it the best he's like kids
are always trying to kill themselves
like that's their job like all they want
to do all day is just kill themselves
about yourselves
exactly I wanted to see oh I remember
this too you know those pallets though
were those with like a wedding palette
the wooden pallets I remember I took off
one of those things and I smashed it
over my friend's head because I want to
see if it was shatter just like in the
movies
wait it must not be the same palette
then you know it is well we just took a
piece obviously he was very hurt oh okay
yeah it wasn't the whole thing it was a
piece of it I just went wow it didn't
break yet if I did that too I had a
buddy in my car anybody but I really
liked him actually I don't know why I
said that
sharpening his pencil over a trash can
like facing the wall like this and I was
like I wonder if his head's gonna go
through the drywall sorry anyway right
through the drywall we got [ __ ]
pissed it so it worked it goes like this
my boo man went crying I ran away and
then he found me and I'm going to
fistfight who won teachers brought us up
I don't to keep disasters they banned us
from playing Power Rangers because
everybody would always fight like this
the Power Rangers would turn to like
real because someone would get hit and
then it would turn into a rumble oh it
was the slap chat or open chest thing I
remember the boys would be playing that
like whenever you open
we did all the way through high school
though until like one of our friends he
was like a world karate champion and he
just wasn't fair they was ready this guy
would [ __ ] like open chest boom and
the blood would come out of our mouth or
some [ __ ] he got me he probably really
liked the game he had all these targets
and like he was so [ __ ] like I just
remember him being so [ __ ] strong
Reggie you [ __ ] [ __ ] we'll try to
open test him right he would just grab
our head or I wrist and Aaron I'm like
[Laughter]
oppa chest with this fool or the the one
with the thing that's that came back bro
I can't have you means is that when you
like get somebody to like yeah I hated
playing that game with my brother cuz
like really quickly I had to learn like
war - look cuz he was like he's ten
years older than me so as soon as you do
that he's like hey can you get this for
me and then he'd like you'd put his hand
clap he's clever Brera my arm like would
fall off he would also stop doing
birthday hits because after a certain
age you're just getting jumped yeah yeah
I got birthday jumped yeah it's like hey
it's your 40th birthday good it was so
weird cuz I'll throw you a party but at
the party to [ __ ] you up exactly it was
like why would you do why this is
awesome then they feed you some cake no
could you imagine though look at it it's
your 40th birthday right you have 10
friends that's 400 punches Oh be a man
David absolutely she called you [ __ ]
that's okay she's sweet and I just meant
oh I do feel kind of worried though
because I feel like the type of
childhood that we had it made us tougher
as kids and then now a tiger like gamma
this hyper sensitive world they're not
even gonna let them like like rough
rough them up so they can become tougher
you know but what if they traumatized us
and broke us really bad I actually read
something pretty recently about how in
America they're trying they're starting
to eradicate recess because all the kids
are on their phones and they don't know
how to interact with each other just
taking everything away it's like but I
mean like think about it if you were 10
and you had a cell phone during recess
like and you're always on Twitter you're
gonna be on your phone on recess the
cat's don't even
know how to communicate with kids aren't
gonna have [ __ ] their death and I'm so I
asked him to I was like hey how many
kids in your and your grade has
cellphones and he's like not that many
maybe like two really oh my god yeah I
don't know what you need a [ __ ] self
on it unless you want to just call home
to get picked up that's why you just get
one of those shitty little phones like a
burner phone a little cube it just has
one button and a speaker and that's it
yeah that's awesome
I did find without a cell phone or
anything and an elementary I was able to
go anywhere I wanted I just had to come
home if it was late or call so I just
memorized the phone number and from
second or third grade on though that was
the rule when the street lights go on go
home right so I would be like three C's
away and then I'd be like oh [ __ ] it's
getting dark and I just call home but
they also want pay phones now no I
called from my friend's house yeah yeah
so I can use your parent your friends
like two things sewn or whatever you go
to school you go to Muay Thai class
after you come right back home but I
also think it creates a smarter kid
maybe I don't know doctor you I want my
kid to be a boy toy
well hi just because I see these little
kids in these class you're protecting
yourself they are [ __ ] amazing well
you won't be able to beat them like your
dream oh yeah and she'll keep
contradicting yourself yeah my bad dude
y'all I'm fine you want a cool class
then you go to pottery class right after
[ __ ] I want to see some buzzes
[ __ ] they're gonna be building
more muscles in their head I want you to
go to sleep class alright I want you to
get some rest will and sleep well if
everyone's supersoft right that means
that they'll pretty much know there
won't be any violent bullies so but
there's mental bullies now yeah exactly
and the world's not getting softer so
your kids gonna know all this martial
arts but they can't even use it you can
beat somebody's ass
hood does it get softer criminals don't
get softer it's just the good kids
getting a hella soft yeah man that's why
when I seed like these like just a fair
skinned nice people walk around pay
salary and is late at night I'm like you
have a very interesting story that's
gonna happen for you tomorrow because
you're gonna get [ __ ] up it actually
happened to my roommates friend decided
to walk around Cape Town drunk by
himself
what happened he got jumped and robbed
he's really that danger they did not yet
yeah really like what hat like what
happens it's actually a lot nicer than
it used to be even like six years ago
when I came here it was it was way well
like I just can't imagine like it you
like it you just in somebody else's
neighborhood and you're walking around
by yourself
dude you're [ __ ] up that's it it just
doesn't look like the safest place in
the world have you been to Cape Town in
LA I went to like Korean barbecue at one
like one time look one I've been in one
time oh yeah well the actual
neighborhood around there and all that
is is it's kind of shady
I think the restaurants are always nice
yeah like your neighbor got murdered
yeah my neighbor got shot in the face
and murdered and then the week before
that somebody got stabbed so I was like
oh cool
recently somebody was like I told
somebody my lease was up and they were
like oh well there's really cheap spots
in k-town cheap for a reason girl yeah
cheap [ __ ] I'm so glad I didn't like
seeing a lot of people that aren't
locals they'll probably move in thinking
oh cool this is pretty affordable
they're in for a [ __ ] nightmare oh my
god are you serious they don't know they
don't they have no idea and it depends
on the building because there are decent
there are some nice places so you might
you might have a nice building where
it's like gated garage park everything
right but then the next building over
might be one of those old deteriorating
buildings with like a bunch of new
cracks and you never know - so the other
day I took a bunch of people out to X
lanes and then we were just balling and
[ __ ] but no behold next to us as I'm
bowling there's three lanes over of all
Bloods
oh - and you know how we knew they were
blood they were all dressed in red and
while they were bowling this is their
face
damn gang soon even fun and on top of
that as we were walking by somebody
grazes dudes ass accidentally he goes
don't [ __ ] touch me [ __ ] I was like
yep you're a gangster oh my god yep so
you never say about that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]